hallo ich bin albertina in bei mir send
sygnis carina gabi marie vanessa
schläfern immer und wir sind heute auf
einer farm in namibia um genau zu sein
auf der vogtland farm und gabriel
stephan wohnen hier und sie haben es uns
heute eingeladen
freundlicherweise um uns mal zu zeigen
wie man auf einer typischen farm in
namibia lebt erinnert euch wir waren vor
kurzem schon einmal auf einer farm
dieser aber ganz anders aus und heute
gucken wir mal was diese gibt vom
tourismus bis zur rinderzucht los geht's
wir stehen jetzt vor dem farmhaus
konnten sie etwas über die geschichte
erzählen
das haus ist von meinen urgroßeltern
erbaut die 1890 aus deutschland
ausgewandert sind des hauses auch so wie
es heute steht aus den materialien der
form gebaut
und weil sind die materialien hier vorne
die weißen rundbögen ist marmor und der
rest des hauses ist aus einem sandstein
dolomit gemisch gebaut
die mauern sowohl als auch der fußboden
wies das haus aufgebaut
das haus ist ein sehr altes haus und her
hinter mir seht ihr dann das eigen
eigentliche haus das er war früher das
wohnhaus und hier
wenn es wenn wir uns herum drehen dann
sehen wir dass es die arbeitsräume waren
und die ochse wagen remise ist jetzt
unser schlafzimmer dann aber die
kinderzimmer waren früher pferdeställe
und futter kammern und das haben wir
jetzt alles umgebaut ist und jetzt alles
wohnräume sie haben auch gästezimmer auf
java was ist das besondere am tourismus
in der bär
das besondere am tourismus in namibia
ist dass die leute auf einer farm urlaub
machen können anstatt in einem großen
hotel die leute gehen gerne auf der farm
um die weite und die ruhe zu genießen
und der massentourismus von den hotels
geht ein wenig zurück würde ich sagen
wir haben selber drei gästezimmer hier
auf der farm wenn ihr wollt dann zeig
ich euch mal welche sodann komma mit ja
nur drei zimmer das ist ein sehr altes
farmhaus ich habe aus den farmhaus alte
möbel rausgesucht wie man hier sehen was
für gäste kommen zu euch zu uns kommen
meistens deutsche gestern zu 80 prozent
würde ich sagen kommen deutsche gäste
die eine selbst fahrradtour hier durchs
land machen
wo sind wie jetzt wir sind jetzt bei den
rindern wir betreiben eine rinderzucht
und hinter uns steht eine mutter erde
kleinen kälbern wie viele diente gibt es
auf der farm wir haben 750 länder auf
7.000 hektar weideland interessieren
würde das ist ja schon völlig anders
hier als ist in deutschland zum beispiel
aussieht oder wie wir es in europa
kennen so was sind die größten
unterschiede in der rinderzucht namibia
deutschland zum beispiel da zum einen
haben wir in namibia ein sehr gesundes
gesundes klima und trockenes klima wenig
parasiten dadurch ist richtig die tiere
werden bei uns sehr gesund wachsen uns
ganz gesund auf ohne jegliches zu futter
und namibia als auch unheimlich stolz
auf die qualität fleischqualität die wir
hier produzieren und auch an die eu
exportieren dürfen
okay was heißt das denn zum beispiel für
die wachsende hierauf dadurch dass es
eine ganze extensive tierhaltung ist
werden unsere wird von unseren kühen
erwartet dass sie die kälber draußen auf
der weide gebären dass sie die kälber
auch beschützen gegen geparden leoparden
die wm und zum teil am tag 5 6 kilometer
zurücklegen müssen um eben zum wasser zu
kommen noch genügend nahrung aufzunehmen
das wäre das wusst ich zum beispiel
alles gar nicht was interessant ist sagt
es gerade getan leoparden jenem sind
hier solche tiere gibt's ja in europa
gar nicht wie können denn die kühe
dagegen sich selbst dagegen beschützen
er ist ganz interessant dass die sich
auch wieso kleine kindergärten
organisieren das ist dann immer so eine
gruppe von 10 15 kälbern mit drei oder
vier mutterkühen die die aufpassen und
die anderen muttertiere dürfen eben auf
die weide gehen gehen zum wasser und
dann am späten nachmittag kommen andere
kühe und dann dürfen die die kälber
wählen des tages gehütet haben dürfen
dann losziehen und fressen und zu wasser
gehen tatsächlich es gibt also so
tagesmütter für kühe ganz genau wer
genau hinsieht man immer wieder so
gruppierungen von 10-15 kälbern zusammen
liegen die aufgepasst werden
aber es ist ja doch dadurch dass die
wildtiere die raubkatzen unheimlich gut
getarnt sind
haben wir doch immer wieder verluste die
wir in kauf nehmen müssen
damit muss man rechnen damit muss man
rechnen und wenn man gerade zu
weitläufig großflächig fahren müssen wir
schon im einklang mit der natur hier
fahren sonst würden wir das gar nicht
schaffen das vom leben in der media city
hier gibt es auf dvd hier auf der farm
haben rinder
wir haben pferde wir haben jede menge
wild tiere
wir haben antilopen vom co zum orix
england antilope haben wasserburger wäre
auch zebras berg zebras am leoparden
geparden
wir haben an haustieren haben wir 100
katzen und schildkröten witzes masse
haben er und sein king mit einer
schildkröte dahin sind noch welche aber
die schlafen jetzt dass auch ein baby
hat mehr da ist noch ein bisschen was
aber alle unsere tiere verstehen sich
gut und weiß ist das wollen wir sind
hier in der khomas region dass es eine
berglandschaften der harte gegend wir
haben unheimlich viel kurz im im boden
so ist es jetzt zeit zu grün weil wir
uns mitten in unserer regenzeit befinden
dass das ein ganz wichtige zeit für uns
als landwirte weil eben das ganze wie
unser vieh nicht zugefüttert wird das
heißt wir sind doch unheimlich abhängig
von dem niederschlag den wir bekommen
einmal um genügend futter für unsere
tiere zu haben und dann aber auch dass
unsere wasserressourcen angereichert
werden
weil wenn es dann im september/oktober
trockene und heiße dann rechnen wir dass
eine kuh pro tag etwa 150 liter am tag
trinkt das war unser besucht auf der
farm danke für sich ein